The Walking Dead has been a whirlwind success
for AMC, and its continued high ratings are
proof that the recent zombie pop culture craze
is more than a fad.
But the show has not been without its fair
share of issues, both on-screen and off.
Here's the behind-the-scenes history of The
Walking Dead you might not know.
Beam me up, Robby
When comic book writer Robert Kirkman first
came up with his concept for The Walking Dead,
he didn't want his idea to fester in some
pile of generic zombie pitches, so he added
a little something extra to the mix: aliens.
Yes, aliens.
Kirkman revealed that when he first approached
publisher Image Comics about his story ideas,
they thought his story needed an extra hook,
so he threw in an otherworldly element, suggesting
that his zombies could have been sent to Earth
by aliens.
Kirkman never intended to follow through with
that plot track, but it got him the green
light.
Ultimately, Kirkman did circle back on the
alien theme in Issue #75, which featured a
bonus ending that had some fun with that original
concept.
Artist bites back
Tony Moore, whose artwork appeared in many
early issues of Kirkman's comic series, filed
suit against the author — his childhood
friend — after he felt duped into signing
over his financial rights to the franchise.
He claimed he was owed a significant slice
of the brainy pie once the series hit it big.
Kirkman disagreed and filed a counter-suit
against Moore, alleging he'd breached their
confidentiality agreement with his filing.
The two amicably settled their dispute in
2012, and Moore returned to draw a variant
cover for The Walking Dead Issue #150, paying
tribute to his cover of issue #1, which debuted
back in 2003.
An intro to remember
A lot of things have changed over the years
on The Walking Dead, but one thing that's
remained the same is that spooky intro music
that lulls us into some undead submission
every episode.
(spooky intro music playing)
Composer Bear McCreary designed the iconic
score, and yes, he intended for it to be just
that dreary.
(live spooky intro music playing)
In a 2010 interview with MTV News, he explained
that he wanted to capture a sense of "emptiness"
with the stringed notes of his opening number,
as it was the feeling he got from watching
it.
He said, "I wanted to create something that
would get stuck in your head, so that when
you hear it, you would think of The Walking
Dead."
Mission accomplished.
Showrunner switcheroo
Frank Darabont was The Walking Dead's first
showrunner, and his fingerprints are still
all over the place.
Not only did he recruit the original cast,
some of whom he'd worked with before, but
he built the world foundation upon which the
show still stands with Robert Kirkman.
So it was a complete shock to him and everyone
else when the network decided to give him
the boot in Season 2.
Darabont pursued legal action against AMC,
accusing the network of creating "crisis-level
problems" by slashing the show's budget in
spite of ratings success and accused executives
of essentially inventing reasons to fire him.
As of the making of this video, Darabont is
seeking more than $280 million in damages.
Jeffrey DeMunn, who'd starred in a ton of
Darabont's movies, including Shawshank Redemption,
The Green Mile, and The Mist, loyally followed
Darabont through the exit sign soon after
his untimely departure.
Pre-Daryl Dixon
Norman Reedus' crossbow-wielding hero Daryl
Dixon has emerged as one of the show's fan-favorite
characters, but Reedus originally auditioned
for the part of Merle, which had already gone
to Michael Rooker.
Showrunners liked Reedus so much, though,
they created the part of Daryl specifically
for him.
Talk about a happy accident.
The jail scene
The prison setting might have been fictional,
but some of The Walking Dead's cast members
have found themselves behind bars in real-life
for their...extracurricular activities.
In 2012, actor Scott Wilson, who played old
man Herschel in the show, was arrested for
drunk driving.
Then in 2015, Seth Gilliam, who plays the
good Reverend Gabriel, was also arrested for
DUI and possession of marijuana.
Sheriff Rick must have been off duty those
nights.
Thanks, Carol
Steven Yeun was born in Seoul, South Korea,
so his parents have something of a language
barrier when it comes to fully understanding
what's happening on the show.
Apparently, in a moment of confusion, they
told him to make sure and thank co-star Melissa
McBride for that time Carol saved everyone
from the cannibals.
Even after Yeun tried to explain that everything
happening on the show is fictional, his father
insisted he thank her, so he did.
Hero dog
Dooley, the dog who played Daryl and Beth's
one-eyed canine companion in Season 4, was
a real-life hero.
He lost his right eye while defending his
owner from a carjacker.
Bravest cast-member ever?
Yup!
Zombie makeup levels
With so many zombified extras at play in any
given episode, the makeup department has had
to be choosy as to which members of its crowd
get the full work-up, so execs devised three
levels of zombies.
The highest is hero, which gets the full body
makeover … like this guy.
"Make sure we slime the back of his head and
shoulders really well."
Then there's midground, which warrants some
facial transformation and costuming.
And when there's a horde of zombies on-screen,
many of the undead extras further away from
the camera just wear a zombie mask and some
ragged clothing.
No matter the level, though, every extra has
to go to zombie school before filming to learn
how to move like a true biter.
(groaning)
"What is that?"
"What about yours?"
"Ay?"
"Who died and made you f***ing king of the
zombies?"
"What?
Oh"
(groaning)
"Yeah, that's pretty good."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw, and let
us know in the comments which Walking Dead
fact surprised you the most...